hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash in the Justice League saved
Christmas video both in the comics
they're a bunch of comic book stories in
on the TV show so here we go
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything during the break so let's start
with the TV show stuff first probably
the best Christmas story was actually
during season two of the flash where you
have the weather wizard trickster
team-up where they basically plant bombs
in all the presents of all the kids
around town they have to find a creative
way to suck all the bombs simultaneously
into wormholes so that they'll explode
elsewhere and won't hurt anybody
so the flash goes down with a couple
really awesome Star Wars Mark Hamill
references and then saves Christmas for
Central City what is this that is a box
with a bow oh it feels so good to give
you see right now there are a hundred
random children of each taking home a
box just like that one and a shove it
under their Christmas tree there's no
way for you to get to all of them even
if you know where to look your toys give
them to me
[Music]
season three didn't really follow up on
that Christmas theme like they did
celebrate the holidays at the end of the
episode but season two's episode was
more of a straight-up Christmas themed
episode because you had Santa Claus yet
all the presents you had the trickster
pulling a joker move and planting bombs
all over the city but onto the comic
book stories so some of these references
you'll probably spot more than others
like this Harley Quinn intro with the
Charlie Brown Christmas is totally on
the nose very apropos I totally love
this so she kind of intros these series
of stories so in-between the one-off
stories like you have Superman saving
Christmas you have Batman saving
Christmas you have the flash saving
Christmas those are all separate stories
the inter connective tissue is this
Charlie Brown Christmas with Harley
Quinn is kind of the mouthpiece that
involves all the DC characters hanging
out together so she says during this
holiday season there's one tradition
that stands out above all the others a
big spanking holiday special so
throughout the whole thing she drops a
bunch of Easter eggs like she even has a
David Bowie being Crosby reference that
I'll explain later
but her joke right here is just making
fun of the idea of big holiday special
comics in general like some of these
characters have absolutely nothing to do
with each other
like she meets the Green Lantern
characters and they're like do eat do we
even know you and she's like nope you
never met me before and they just go on
to the next story so just like you see
in Deadpool comics it's very self
referential they like to make fun of
themselves when they do big stories like
this that aren't necessarily part of the
Canon so even though some of these
stories like the Superman one that I'll
tell first invoke a lot of classic canon
this big party that they're having isn't
technically canon so first story
Superman and Superboy saved Christmas
it's actually a Krypto story about how
he's had this really awful year like
they referenced the big fight that he
had with the Eradicator earlier in the
year that actually happened during the
Superman comic book the inter-gang
storyline they referenced here
this is all part of the canon but then
the John Kent Superboy if you didn't
know if you haven't been reading the
Superman comic he's named after Jonathan
Kent himself so they just call him John
jo-anne Kent he has the idea that they
need to get crypto a present so
Superman's like alright I have a great
idea let's go
so we peláez him to the fortress of
solitude and shows him the Museum of
artifacts that he houses there like it's
this giant repository for alien
artifacts special things that need to be
protected he even has an alien zoo for
creatures that are on the endangered
species list across the universe so john
gets super excited starts running around
like a kid in a candy store and sees
Superman's classic comic book costume
and Superman explains this is the suit
that I met your mother in it was from a
long time ago it meant a lot to me it
was meant to represent my heritage
so John gets a really bright idea that
he's going to use Superman's classic
belt and turn it into Kryptos new collar
so it's a really fun way for them to
bring something back from the classic
comics in a really touching way so the
next story is actually kind of like
Batman ruining Christmas in a very
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation
way where everyone's opening presents
Harley Quinn's getting really excited
like she got a gift from Superman here
then Batman kind of shied away and
Wonder Woman makes fun of him did you
forget to get presents for everyone and
he's like just wait a minute wait for it
in everywhere all the characters on
their cell phones get messages that
Bruce Wayne has made a donation in their
name to the police Retirement Fund so
everyone's like god damn it that is the
worst president ever you've ruined
Christmas for us in Batman does his
Kermit none of my business pose here if
mr. Wayne were here I'm sure he'd say
you're welcome so the next story Wonder
Woman kind of explains what their
Christmas traditions are their holiday
traditions on Paradise Island she says
you know we don't really celebrate
Christmas in the traditional sense but
we do dress someone up who gives us
gifts we try to unmask them that
initiates combat the losers are dressed
up in doe suits they run off we hunt
them down like animals then skin them
ceremonially and wrap them up like we're
baking them in a giant pastry shell like
lid
early baking people in pastry shells so
just the look on Harley Quinn's face
here as priceless they panned a Superman
and he's kind of like well I went in my
house we just put up a tree and then
Wonder Woman counters with another even
more hardcore statement did you know
that the history of Christmas trees are
steeped in bloody sacrifice and sorcery
just reminding you that Wonder Woman's
roots are that of a warrior she's way
more hardcore than most of the Justice
League members then the next story is
the flash saving Christmas it's flash
Christmas Carol so it's not necessarily
ghosts of past present and future
they're really just borrowing that name
somatically it's a much different story
it's just the flash basically saving
Christmas from the Rogues like he's here
visiting one of his friends who has a
foster home there's a young child who's
really excited about Christmas he tries
to explain what Christmas was like when
he was growing up when he was in a
foster home himself like Christmas was
very important for me
traditions were very important I want to
make you feel very special in this
holiday time too so he tries to explain
the concept of Santa Santa has a lot of
special helpers and then they pan to the
Rogues who are in the process of robbing
the bank ho ho ho Merry Christmas
so they have weather wizard
creates snow cover turning it into a
white Christmas just burying the entire
area and snow while they're inside the
bank they almost get some money until
the flash walks in breaking all the
glass but then surprise surprise
Captain Cold has planted bombs around
the city to keep the flash busy for a
couple minutes so Captain Cold knows
that the flash is going to be able to
find the bombs get back and capture them
so in that time he gets one bag of money
out of the bank via mirror master while
the rest of the Rogues try to get the
rest of the haul out via a truck the
flash is able to stop them but not
without Captain Cold downing a truck
that has a bunch of presents bound for
all these foster children all over the
city so Captain cold makes a truce with
the flash that he doesn't want to ruin
all these kids Christmases because
Captain colt had a terrible childhood
Barry had a terrible childhood so sort
of like the hopeful message here is the
Captain Cold is a thief but he has his
honor and he isn't a total so
he says I will
get you after the new year I'm gonna
make your life a living hell but I'm not
gonna ruin Christmas for a bunch of
foster kids so he gives the flash up
past the flash is able to take all the
presents around town Santa style because
the truck that was carrying them was
totaled so the flash becomes Santa Claus
for the night and then between all these
you have a rankin/bass adventure if you
guys haven't watched the rankin/bass
cartoons in a while that's actually fun
to do during the holidays but Rudolph
was one of the big stories so in this
version of events the cold themed
villains from the DC Universe Captain
cold killer frost and mr. freeze team up
to rob Santa Claus
but then Harley Quinn rides in on Krypto
who takes them down and then because the
reindeer aren't able to fly without some
help lets them borrow Krypto who kind of
becomes the Rudolph of the story leading
the sleigh so just a lot of really fun
twist on classic comic-book stories but
let me know like what is your favorite
DC or marvel themed holiday story it
doesn't have to be Christmas it can be
any holiday but because there are so
many others I'm gonna do a couple more
holiday themed comic book videos the
Marvel one actually isn't dropping till
next week the new Marvel holiday special
so I'll do a video for that after I post
but there's a bunch of other spider-man
Deadpool Avengers holiday stories so
they'll be more of that this weekend the
Batmobile lost the wheel
so happy holidays everyone
and congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner
Spidey geek please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video so just
announced the winner the next time I
post a DC video so I'll be doing like
the ring spider-man giveaway stuff all
week long just because of the holidays
so everybody get hype hopefully you're
opening presents tomorrow hopefully we
get a Justice League trailer really soon
too so we're still on trailer watch it
could come any time in the next week so
just be on high alert while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for the trailer for the next episode of
the flash and you can click here for the
legends of tomorrow trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight